Rob here with some sad sad news those of
you gamers who like to linger on to your
old favorite titles rather than change
to the next and latest triple-a
something's coming that's right 2k games
has announced the games that will be
saved from the game spy server shutdowns
and the games that will lose the online
support games by technology was a
service that many publishers used to
operate their online multiplayer servers
rather than purchasing and running their
own servers for each game game spy
technology was bought by mobile game
developer Glu Mobile in 2012 and they
have gradually been shutting down the
multiplayer servers ever since with the
final blow coming at the end of May 2k
games will be transferring Borderlands
on PC in Civilization three and four two
valves steam works service so they
should only go offline temporarily
during the switchover some of the games
that are Slade to lose online
functionality are Borderlands for ps3
civilization revolution for ps3 and
nintendo DS Vietcong one and two an NHL
2k10 and NBA 2k10 for Wii 2k says it is
currently looking into the technical
feasibility of transitioning Borderlands
ps3 and civilization revolution ps3 to
another network but as of now they will
go offline 2k is not the only publisher
affected by the game spy shutdown crytek
announced last week that the pc versions
of crisis and Crysis 2 are also going
offline while EA has pledged to find a
way to keep old Battlefield games online
after May 31st to be clear you can still
play these games offline but any online
multiplayer will be disabled here at
gamespot com we'll be keeping you up to
date with any of the at-risk games that
have been threatened by the games by
server shutdown our hearts go out to
those who have been affected
you